Philippe Vigier bonjour bonjour député
MoDem de réloire la partie sud de
l'Eure-et-Loir un Châteaudun absolument
ça peut servir des biologistes à
l'Assemblée nationale en ce moment parce
que il y a des tas d'espèces à observer
Gabriel Attal déploie ce matin son plan
contre la fraude sociale c'est dans Le
Parisien il veut fusionner carte vitale
et carte d'identité c'est une bonne
mesure et renonce à aucun résultat
biométrique il préfère ça il y a juste
un chiffre que tout le monde doit
connaître il y a 2 millions de cartes
vitales en France en plus qu'une nombre
d'habitants dans quelque part il y a une
anomalie j'ai pu constater dans mon labo
puisque c'est biologiste c'est vrai
qu'il y avait des fausses cartes
d'itales des gens qui circulaient des
cartes n'étaient pas les leurs donc ils
en puisse bien identifier la personne je
crois que c'est la moindre des choses
puisque quelque part c'est l'assurance
maladie qui rembourse les actes qui sont
faits alors il veut demander aussi le
ministre aux patients de signaler les
factures bizarres que les patients
reçoivent notamment en dentaires en
ophtalmologie pour voir s'il y a pas des
actes non pratiqués qui ont été facturés
à la sécu des nations acceptable ou ça
marchera pas écoutez l'assurance maladie
c'est combien c'est 180 milliards on
sait très bien que l'on doit dépenser
plus d'argent pour mieux payer nos
personnel de santé ce qui dans la covid
est en première ligne et il faut bien
comprendre aussi qu'il y a c'est vrai
des actes qui ne sont facturés et qui ne
sont pas réalisés et d'ailleurs un
nouveau confrères et qui a fait le truc
il y a une émission de télévision il y a
quelques semaines et qui démontrer tout
cela et d'ailleurs dans le rapport de la
Cour des comptes c'est expressément
indiqué donc oui il faut mieux payer les
professionnels de santé toutes ces
discussions vous savez sur le Seigneur
et moi je préfère qu'on les paye mieux
et je préfère surtout qu'on évite toutes
ces fraudes c'est quoi ils sont pas
acceptables pour toucher des allocations
sociales en France il faudra justifier
de 9 mois de résidence obligatoire et
non plus 3-6-8 selon les les prestations
ça aussi c'est une bonne mesure oui
c'est une bonne mesure et en plus nous
compatriotes ne comprennent pas que
certains puissent se disposer de ces
mesures là et que eux quelquefois ils
ont ce qu'on appelle un reste à charge
pour se soigner qui ne peuvent pas payer
tout ça ça sera voté si ça passe à
l'Assemblée beaucoup de choses vont
passer par décret beaucoup de choses par
décret mais écoutez je pense que toutes
les sensibilités politiques sont
sensibles à ça je me souviens si Lionel
Jospin je me souviens c'est la gauche ou
toujours des mesures de anti fraude j'ai
fait d'ailleurs il y a une dizaine
d'années avec albéric de Montgolfier qui
était rapporte en général du budget au
Sénat un rapport dans lesquels nous
avions expliqué qu'il y avait des frais
de social à virer qui fallait lutter
contre celle-ci moi je préfère que cet
argent-là vous voyez ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'on l'utilise pour mieux soigner
pour apporter à nos soignants plus de
moyens alors il y a un petit point de
litige entre Gabriel Attal et Gérald
Darmanin Gérald Darmanin dans une
interview récente veut vraiment durcir
la me la droite d'ailleurs a demandé
carrément la suppression c'était de
médical d'État Gabriel dit non faut la
préserver parce que les professionnels
de santé nous la demande ça permet de
soigner de surveiller les tasses
sanitaires mais faut peut-être la
repenser un petit peu où est votre
position à vous
mais pas sous la forme que l'on connaît
à l'heure actuelle oui il y a un certain
nombre de choses qui se passe dans les
maux qui sont pas acceptables en
revanche nous maintiendrons cet ame on
voudra l'aménager je m'explique par
exemple il peut y avoir des prothèses
mammaires qui sont financés tout de
l'Ame ça n'a pas lieu d'être là
quelqu'un en revanche qui est en
situation de détresse de santé on doit
le soigner c'est l'honneur de la France
le président de la République et de
l'humanisme que nous incarnons donc la
droite ne vous convaincra pas sur ce
terrain là
était ouvert et qui était pris à des
aménagements je vois Gabriel t'as dit la
même chose en tout cas sur le web c'est
l'immigration qui arrive par exemple sur
la me ne seront porteurs les centrices
les démocrates d'un message comme nous
serons portions d'ailleurs sur la
régularisation des travailleurs qui sont
là depuis 5 10 15 ans et puis qui ont
des difficultés pour une carte de séjour
si cela veut devenir Français pourquoi
pas est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un effet
d'appel d'air si on régularise des
travailleurs en situation régulière même
si ils sont là depuis 5 ans non il faut
pas confondre deux choses ce que veulent
par exemple les insoumis et la dupesse
dire on régularise tout le monde il en
est hors des questions après il y a la
droite ou l'extrême droite qui dit
régularise personne mais ça ne marche
pas même madame melonien elle fait quoi
sur les métiers en tension elle a prévu
un programme de régularisation mais les
celles et ceux qui veulent être français
qui maîtrisent les Français qui
respectent la République et respecte
leur symbole ses symboles de la
République et puis vous savez l'échelle
d'entreprise quoi disons les choses bas
les masques
et cela il faut l'irrégulariser ceux qui
bossent est-ce que ce n'est pas à eux
chef d'entreprise de faire des cours de
langue de les former et de les apporter
l'administration disons voilà cet
employé modèle je veux qu'on le
régularise plutôt une très bonne idée
oui oui il faut lui former il faut qu'il
parle le français bien sûr en tout cas
nous on peut faire l'effort les
collectivités peuvent faire les formes
mais je crois que c'est dans
l'entreprise il y a les plans de
formation individuels oui je crois que
mettre l'accent là-dessus il y a une
ligne rouge dans la négociation entre le
gouvernement et la droite sur
l'immigration c'est le respect des
traités européens la droite propose de
son exonérer en réformant la
Constitution est-ce que ça vous semble
envisageable acceptable non c'est pas
acceptable il y a deux choses d'abord il
y a la fameuse convention de Genève de
1951 rappelle qu'il en semble des pays
du monde se sont mis d'accord sur des
conditions justement pour les droits
d'asile mais deuxième chose les traités
européens dont on échappera pas et puis
son film réforme constitutionnelle vous
savez mieux que moi que c'est soit le
plus dans la République soit c'est un
référendum donc c'est remis tout ça à 8
ou à 10 mois donc ça n'a pas de sens non
réforme constitutionnelle non réforme
migratoire oui bien sûr je crois comme
un porte un certain nombre de mesures
d'ailleurs partagez pas la droite et sur
le texte qui a été déjà qui est passé au
Sénat à la commission des lois il y a eu
un accord et cet accord là c'est la
droite c'est notoriale et le sentimental
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire mais
bien sûr triste du Sénat avec Hervé
Marseille ont pointé la Mure voulant le
modifier comme je le proposer tout à
l'heure il faut repartir de cette base
là le texte du Sénat plutôt que les
textes qui vont être déposés là parler
l'air et qu'on a vu dans la presse et
c'est ce qu'elle est plus facile il a
qu'une fragilité c'est une proposition
de loi comme si une proposition de loi
il est pas passé au Conseil d'État donc
une fragilité juridique pour autant
c'est un texte solide sur lequel une
fois de plus de grandes familles
politiques du Sénat et majoritairement
sont mis d'accord et je pense c'est une
bonne matière pour avancer à l'Assemblée
nationale les traités européens le
Danemark a obtenu le droit de son
exonérer pour partie c'est ce qui a
permis au Danemark de faire une
politique migratoire très très sévère
c'est ça il demande la droite finalement
oui mais à part que sur le droit d'asile
le Danemark n'a pas eu ce que vu n'a pas
mis en place que souhaite faire les
républicains dans le fameux rapport
qu'ils ont sorti dans lequel ils disent
que le droit d'asile doit être demandé à
l'extérieur accessoirement je rappelle
que dans la ligne aka de la Constitution
il est marqué qu'il sera d'asile et
chacun peut lui demander sur le
territoire français
la reine et l'héritier c'est ce
qui a affirmé Elisabeth borne sur
radiologie ce week-end est-ce que ça
vous semble juste historiquement
excessif politiquement excessif
politiquement chacun a ses mots je les
enclerai pas comme cela elle fait des
certainement référence au Front national
de Jean-Marie Le Pen qui pour lequel les
fours crématoires est-il des détails de
l'histoire mais je crois que rien n'a
changé en revanche je vous le dis très
clairement lorsque le médecin Brévin
vous savez dans tous parlé mais ça nous
ont brûlé lorsqu'il a été menacé par des
groupes d'extrême droite moi j'ai vu
qu'il y a eu plusieurs députés rassemble
national qui ne sont pas levés et ça ce
n'est pas bien parce que ma mère c'est
un serviteur de la République c'est un
agent de l'État lorsqu'on touche un
maire on touche la République la
filiation entre l'extrême droite d'hier
et l'extrême droite d'aujourd'hui il y a
pas trop encore
ils ont encore alors ça quelques
extrémistes c'est extrémiste là c'est là
on peut pas laisser passer on doit rien
lâcher jamais rien lâcher dessus
l'obscurantisme jamais le fond on n'a
pas changé d'Elizabeth borde même si
Marine Le Pen a fait un ripolinage de
façade ah elle a quand même pris ses
distances très largement avec son père
moi je suis pas là pour la défense
simplement moi je me bats sur les idées
vous savez quand en revanche quand tu
nous racontes que tout le monde regarde
la retraite à 60 ans à taux plein c'est
ça ce sont des histoires qui tiennent à
nous racontes que en baissant la TVA le
pouvoir d'achat vous va augmenter de
façon considérable c'est encore plus de
démagogiques d'extrémités par exemple
c'est le gouvernement qui décide
d'augmenter les salaires de 10 % mais on
n'a jamais vu une entreprise dans lequel
c'est l'administes augmenter les
salaires des salariés ça c'est encore
une histoire moi je me bats sur leur
projet et c'est là je vois par exemple
sur les retraites où j'étais très
impliqué ou alors projet j'ai cherché
alors j'ai trouvé une ligne on
augmentera les petites retraites on sait
pas de combien on sait pas combien
d'années faut avoir cotiser
extraordinaire on se souvient de Dreux
en 83 c'est pas loin de chez vous c'est
là que la droite est l'extrême droite
avait la pour la première fois trouver
une alliance pour prendre la mairie ça
avait fait scandale c'était il y a 40
ans cette perspective d'une alliance
lrrenne pour vous elle peut revenir même
au niveau national quand on lit les
propos de Laurent Wauquiez très à droite
on verra bien en tout cas moi j'avais
parti là-dedans puisque en aucun cas
j'ai trop vécu de rue avec Jean-Pierre
bois qui avait été élu à l'époque mère
de droite depuis
écoutez pour moi il y a un cordon
sanitaire il y a des choses sur
lesquelles on ne peut pas transigerai
jamais et d'ailleurs la région Centre
Val de Loire je rappelle que c'est
original depuis longtemps nous avions
mis encore dans sanitaire avec
Jacqueline Gouraud qui maintenant est
membre du Conseil constitutionnel en 98
la proposition de loi liotte qui veut
abroger la réforme des retraites connaît
toute une série de d'épisodes importants
c'est en ce moment
ericoquerel le président de la
commission des finances ne veut pas
activer l'article 40 qui dit que le
Parlement ne doit pas créer de charges
supplémentaires il a raison liberté
parlementaire où il a tort
il a tort pour une raison simple en
laissant passer cela ça veut dire que
les députés qui sont censés
respecter la Constitution ça roge un
droit d'inconstitutionnalité on sait
très bien que ce texte il a d'ailleurs
suite aux conséquationnel et bien il
n'ira pas plus loin parce qu'il déclara
justement pas conforme à la Constitution
écouter va avoir lieu moi je fais partie
de ceux qui disent quoi
activé s'il n'est pas un débat il ira
d'abord la commission puis on verra si
oui ou non ça sera demain c'est demain
la commission
de quelques LR pour annuler cet article
1 qui ramène à 62 ans ils vont suivre ou
pas il faut avoir une majorité on verra
je crois que c'est interroger que moi
mais ils vont quand même réfléchir les
uns et les autres toute l'histoire le
texte des LR du Sénat c'est quoi c'est
64 ans vous le savez comme moi Valérie
Pécresse porter 65 ans ce texte ne porte
pas autant de justice qu'on veut le dire
au contraire il apporte quelques
solutions il a été mal vendu mal ficelé
mal expliqué et c'est bien dommage parce
que par exemple moi je parle souvent des
femmes parce que j'ai porté ces mesures
là avec un mec il y a des mesures fortes
sur les femmes que nous avons pris ce
sont ceux qui ont plus de cariérarchie
et pour lesquelles on apporte le plus de
réponses il y aura après la commission
si le texte n'est pas annulé le retour
le débat le 8 juin est-ce que vous
demandez la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale d'activer l'article 40 ça
revenait d'elle la décision lui
appartient si elle l'active je pense ça
serait juste ça serait bien parce que
sinon on retombe ce que je lui ai
expliqué il y a un instant c'est
inconstitutionnalité à la clé et ça
serait quand même dommage qu'on se fasse
censuré par le Conseil constitutionnel
ensuite bon et puis après si il est pas
activé mais écoutez il y aura le débat
pas d'obstruction mais il y aura un
débat au fond parce que on a été privé
débat vous savez 175 heures de débats
nous on n'a pas pu débattre justement on
n'a pas pu débat des carrières
difficiles on n'a pas pu débattre des
seniors pour lesquels obstruction de
vérifier la marque centriste la clause
de revoyure en clair un bilan ami
parcours pour voir si cette réforme est
calibrée
répond aux attentes ou pas et bien on
voit que c'est nous serons prêts 300
amendements un débat de fond et hop on
dépasse minuit il y aura pas de vote
sujet c'est pas de dépasser de 1000 non
je vais pointer leurs incohérences je
connais bien Charles de Corseau c'est
celui qui m'a accueilli l'assemblée
c'est celui qui m'a formé par la
commission des finances j'ai travaillé
13 ans avec lui dans le coup il est très
bien je vais essayer de lui expliquer
comment est signé les amendements avec
moi
il demandait leur frite à 65 ans elle
explique maintenant que le texte est
injuste je lui ai demandé pourquoi avec
son texte une rétablit pas les régions
spéciaux que nous avons supprimé alors
que depuis 15 ans il m'explique faut
tous les supprimer vous voyez que les
incohérences sont peut-être pas toujours
là où on pense mais il dit ces jours-ci
bah le gouvernement de façon il va
tomber bientôt mais pour faire quoi un
contre gouvernement avec la nuit pèse et
puis le RN vous imaginez un peu ce truc
là un peu multiforme qui va se produire
un dernier mot sur le modèle est-ce que
vous êtes en train de préparer l'après
Macron donc après Bayrou
François bayrouella elle est solide
un mot sur les retraites vous allez
pouvoir que c'était le premier qui avait
expliqué les écueils le temps qu'il
fallait dire aux Français qui avait
quand même 30 milliards difficiles tout
le monde s'en fout mais là le texte
liotte Sipa j'aurais dû le dire tout à
l'heure c'est encore 15 milliards de
plus alors que la note de la France a
été dégradée non voyez Jean-Paul Mattei
nous avons proposé vous savez la fameuse
Saxe de super dividende j'ai proposé la
fameuse de revoyure donc nous sommes là
et puis dernier mot qui me paraît
essentiel le modem porte une chose
indispensable c'est quoi de mieux
associer les citoyens aux décisions et
bien vous reviendrez pour nous parler de
tous ces sujets Philippe Vigier merci
bonne journée merci beaucoup oui
messieurs et on retiendra la phrase le
texte de la réforme des retraites ne
porte pas autant d'injustices qu'on le
croit merci Christophe on vous retrouve
demain demain en compagnie de David
Lisnard maire de Cannes et président de
l'Association des maires de France à
demain à demain
retrouvez le barbier du